3.0 a represent and solve problems in
solving involving multiplication
right test date excuse me don't hatch in
my classroom will you please take that
house thank you
all right everybody what are you looking
at no no okay three times four do it do
it right now right now look you don't
know it don't you
seen
ethan will you tell me what the number
three stands for in this equation it's
like the amount of something
in that equation will you agree class do
you agree
sure great
uh tina will you please tell me what the
number four stands in this equation how
many times the number of times that we
need to
do it add the threes great class do you
agree
yes you agree ethan will you please
stand up he's a third grader so
ethan
he's standing up
fail teacher phil that's okay it's it's
human nature to fail and that's okay so
check it out ethan you have the three
things right that you're gonna do will
you please come up with a set of three
movements
one two three nice ethan you have to you
have to use those three movements and
how many times they're going to repeat
them four times will you please show me
that one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
three times four is twelve glass i can't
hear you
all right so
the problem that we've identified is
that standardized education
produces students that are not engaged
our solution
our solution is we're going to make fun
project based learning how are we going
to do that we're going to use dance and
all the arts going do it all together
what are we going to do after that we're
going to collect the data after we
collect the data we're going to show it
to policy changers we're going to tell
them you need to do this after we do
that they're going to like us on
facebook give us money and arts
integration will happen everybody will
have fun
we should say that we're not really only
testing for grades we're testing for
we're not only collecting data for
grades we're collecting data for
engagement we want students to feel
engaged with youtube
so
do you think administrators are going to
have fun also with the fun
thing who the administrators are they're
going to have fun
um i think they're going to have fun
first of all because they're going to
see the whole community of the classroom
changing
and the students having fun with it and
they're going to be like well you know
this actually works our students are
engaged our students are doing fun
things and they want to be here whereas
before they really didn't want to be
here so
fun is going to come from the students
from the ground up into the whole school
community and can you control the fun
yeah what because it's uh structured
chaos
well you control it because these are
not just activities that we're like
doing to play games these are
we're design we're designing the
activities
all student-centered and all connected
to the common core
um
and
based on student interest so it's fun
learning but it's also guided
explorations
that the teacher is
doing and if the teacher does not want
to do it
well if the teacher doesn't want to do
it it's one of the things where
you you know you can't it has to start
in a way you have to start with the
teacher
it's one of those things where if the
teacher doesn't want to do it well then
this is not the right thing
for that teacher
i it's one of the things maybe it's one
of the things where
also teachers you identify a teacher
that would be willing to pr um to
prototype this in their classroom and as
the buzz of those students being
successful and engaged the word spreads
and it grows out within your community
thank you
it's just it's a activity within the day
like they use it you imagine it's five
minutes a day from each every one of
their teachers or how what does it look
like it can it can grow in any direction
five minutes all the way through the
whole day experiential learning
collaborative learning all different
kinds of learning